portrait ciselé du numéro 1 chinois avec
ce documentaire Le monde selon si Jean
Ping réalisé par Sophie Lepot et Romain
Franklin avec nous venons de le voir le
parcours chaotique de ce prince rouge
aux allures affables mais qui a grand
renfort de nationalité
ambitionnent désormais de faire de son
pays la première puissance économique et
militaire mondiale faut-il s'en
inquiéter jusqu'où ira l'appétit
idéologie de celui qui concentre depuis
plus de 10 ans maintenant tous les
pouvoirs en République populaire de
Chine nous allons en débattre maintenant
avec nos invités présents sur ce plateau
de débat doc avec vous pour commencer
Antoine bondas bienvenue vous êtes
chercheur à la Fondation pour la
recherche stratégique spécialiste de la
Chine et des deux Corées et par ailleurs
enseignant à Sciences Po Paris on vous a
vu à l'instant un témoigner dans ce
documentaire et puis également avec nous
Chloé Froissart bienvenue et vous êtes
sinologue et psychologues professeur au
Département d'études chinoises de
l'inalquo linalco l'Institut national
des langues et civilisations orientales
pierre Aski est également avec nous on
vous a vu également Pierre ASCII dans ce
documentaire bienvenue vous présenter
bien sûr une chronique géopolitique
chaque matin c'est dans la matinale de
nos confrères de France Inter vous êtes
vous aussi un grand connaisseur de la
Chine et vous êtes par ailleurs le
président de reporter sans frontières
merci à vous d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau de débat doc aujourd'hui une
précision d'emblée pour ceux qui
viennent de voir ce documentaire il a
été tourné dans une première version en
2018 autrement dit il y a maintenant
quatre ans et vous venez de voir vous
venez de découvrir une version d'attente
cette fois de 2021 intégrant la
problématique du covid qui n'était pas
présente dans la première version
qui était disponible dans ce
documentaire c'est une précision
importante parce que ça va nous
permettre d'une certaine manière de
réactualiser évidemment le film que nous
venons de voir ensemble pour commencer à
qui a-t-on à faire Antoine gondas avec
jijin ping on le comprend un petit peu
avec ce film il y a Querry Brown qui est
un ancien ambassadeur britannique qui
était en place à Pékin qui a ce mot à
propos de sigin ping si est un homme de
foi
pour lui Dieu est le Parti communiste
voilà et selon lui tout est dit en ayant
dit cela c'est vrai ou alors le parti et
la religion commune aujourd'hui et de
plus en plus en Chine alors c'est très
difficile de se baser sur la
personnalité de Jean Ping puisqu'on
aurait été très peu d'informations on a
des éléments biographiques on a
certaines déclarations lorsqu'il était
en poste au fujen dans d'autres
provinces et puis ensuite quand il est
devenu vice-président de la République
avant de devenir secrétaire général
président de la commission militaire
centrale et président de la République
populaire de Chine les trois titres
qu'il a aujourd'hui on en sait au final
peu de choses ce qui est sûr c'est qu'il
a réussi à concentrer le pouvoir comme
peu de foi auparavant et qu'il y ait eu
depuis 10 ans un phénomène extrêmement
intéressant sur le plan institutionnel
de concentration du pouvoir dans la
société autour du parti et dans le parti
autour de chez une fille est-ce qu'il y
a un surnom chez inping en Chine
surnom pour donner beaucoup lors de son
premier mandat on le donne un petit peu
moins maintenant c'était shidada
c'est-à-dire alors on traduisait ça
souvent par l'oncle chie c'était un
surnom bienveillant qui était donné à
celui qui était un petit peu le petit
père de la nation mais mais ça a l'air
d'être un moine un moine communiste
évidemment tout le paradoxe mais ce qui
est clair c'est que
un rouge parmi les rouges dit-on il y a
une communication extrêmement bien rodée
autour de sa personne et notamment dans
les interactions qu'il peut avoir au
sein du parti ou à propos du parti on
voit par exemple qu'après chaque congrès
avec le nouveau comité permanent du
bureau politique aller sur des sites
emblématiques de l'histoire du Parti
communiste et véritablement inséré
intégrer son exercice du pouvoir dans
l'histoire plus longue du parti à la
fois pour rappeler évidemment que le
parti et l'organisation centrale en
Chine mais aussi lui-même s'inscrire
dans le parti pour avoir une
légitimité à chaque fois renouvelée
alors il était marié deux fois je crois
dans la dernière fois avec la soprano
superstar en Chine à l'époque peigne lui
Yang excusez-moi pour la prononciation
c'est en 1987 alors il y a une ancienne
cadre du PCC qui est depuis exilé du
côté des États-Unis qui estiment que si
j'ai une pink souffre d'un complexe
d'infériorité sachant qu'il est peu
éduqué par rapport aux autres aux
dirigeants du Parti communiste chinois
il aurait un complexe d'infériorité ce
qui justifierait selon elle tout de même
un caractère têtu et dictatoriale je
sais pas c'est extrêmement difficile à
dire et je m'aventurerai pas sur sur ce
terrain là ce qui est clair c'est qu'il
a fait ses preuves au sein du parti
pendant plusieurs décennies il a gravé
les échelons comme à peu près tous les
cadres dirigeants du Parti communiste
même si on pourrait considérer qu'au 20e
congrès il y a eu des promotions
peut-être un peu plus rapide que lors
des congrès 20e congrès c'est important
de le signaler c'était en octobre
dernier il ne figurait pas évidemment
dans ce film que nous venons de voir sur
20e congrès exactement donc il y a avant
tout du côté de chez Jean Ping une
expérience
accumuler au fil des ans un leadership
qui a été en partie imposée évidemment
au sein du parti des outils de contrôle
du parti et du leadership du parti donc
complexe d'infériorité ou pas je n'en
sais rien après évidemment le clin
d'oeil c'est de dire que lorsqu'il a
épousé pinguel elle était plus connue
que lui à l'époque ça n'empêche que
aujourd'hui chez une ping est de loin le
plus puissant en Chine et de loin bien
plus puissant que sa femme avec un culte
de la personnalité autour de du numéro
un chinois aujourd'hui la personnalité
et on voit évidemment à travers
l'analyse de la presse chinoise plus
largement des médias chinois une image
parfaitement construite de ginking et
quasiment de l'infaillibilité de chez
une ping on y reviendra peut-être y
compris sur la question du covid alors
évidemment on peut pas s'empêcher de
faire les comparaisons
lorsqu'on parle de la République
populaire de Chine depuis 49 il y a
trois noms qui sortent en réalité
Mao tenter et visiblement si j'ai une
pink si on a bien compris ce qui nous
est dit dans ce documentaire c'est la
réalité fait partie de ces croix figures
qualifiés d'historique aujourd'hui on
peut le comparer à Mao si j'ai une pink
alors juste pour rebondir ce que la
question précédente je pense qu'il y a
deux éléments biographiques extrêmement
importants pour comprendre la
personnalité sitting d'une part c'est le
fils de sidom un général de l'armée
qui a été un héros de la révolution qui
était un modèle qui a été purgé en 62
qui a dû passer 16 ans de travail forcé
en usine également est envoyé à la
campagne ou de la suivi également
sitting dans les conditions extrêmement
compliquées une de ses sœurs a été
persécutée par les garde-rouges une
autre s'est suicidé donc c'est quelqu'un
qui a subi
le régime totalitaire maoïste de plein
fouet et qui s'est sans doute dit qu'il
valait mieux du côté des puissants des
des vainqueurs que les vaincus enfin des
dominants des dominés et c'est un peu ce
qui est dit dans le documentaire
quelqu'un fait référence au syndrome de
Stockholm et dans la lignée de cette
pseudo psychologisation de son vécu on
peut aussi mentionner le fait que une
chose anti-inping c'est la chute de
l'URSS et la première chose qu'il a dit
en arrivant au pouvoir c'est que la
Chine a besoin d'un homme fort
pour empêcher le délitement du
communisme et du régime politique
chinois qu'il voyait à la fin de l'ère
routine
faisant un peu figure voilà de de l'air
Gorbatchev puisqu'il y avait voilà une
tendance vers une libéralisation du
régime et que ça et pour sitting
libéraliser réformer c'est se montrer
faible et c'est courir à la perte de
régime et donc d'où c'est quelqu'un qui
n'a pas qui ne juge positivement la
déstabilisation par exemple et qui au
contraire avait quand même une certaine
amélioration par pour Staline comme
l'avait Mao d'ailleurs ça c'est des
choses qu'on peut lire ici ou là
lorsqu'on s'intéresse un peu à
oui enfin il y avait des rivalités
extrêmement importantes mais je pense
que ce qui est vraiment important de
souligner c'est que simpling un carne
l'ordre la sécurisation et la volonté de
reprise de contrôle sur la société et en
ce sens il a restauré une forme de
totalitarisme étant une volonté jamais
complètement réalisée de contrôle total
à la fois sur le parti et sur la société
et en cela est-ce qu'il est comparable à
Mao pour en revenir à ce qui était
absolument alors il y a des grandes
différences pour le question de complexe
de d'infériorité que vous mentionnez
tout à l'heure il me semble en effet
peut-être qu'on peut en déceler un dans
le fait que Mao était avait une
véritable légitimité un charisme
personnel incontestable incontesté dans
la mesure où c'était l'artisan à la fois
sur le plan théorique et pratique de la
révolution chinoise le fondateur du
régime
celui qui est adapté le communisme à la
Chine alors que c'est une ping lui n'a
aucune légitimité sur ce plan là donc il
y a au ping lui c'est l'artisan des
réformes qu'est-ce qui a fait sitting on
ne sait pas par ailleurs il est diplômé
de team croix il a fait une thèse en
marxisme dans la légitime contester
également
donc par contre il a un charisme
institutionnalisé bien plus
institutionnalisé que le laver Mao
il est par exemple
dès 2016 il a été nommé
corleader
noyau dirigeants du parti en 2017 sa
pensée pour le socialisme dans une
nouvelle caractéristique chinoises dans
une nouvelle ère a été introduit dans
les statues du parti alors que tous ces
prédécés d'or ont dû attendre la fin de
leur mandat pour voir la combustion
théorique reconnue
et donc c'est quelqu'un qui jouit d'une
assise institutionnelle et pour ça il a
il a il est parvenu au pouvoir en
s'appuyant sur les institutions
contrairement à Mao qui s'appuyait sur
les masses sur les mobilisations de
masse et si une Ping a
on peut dire exercer le poids
peut-être une concentration des pouvoirs
exerce le pouvoir de manière beaucoup
plus continue que ne l'a jamais fait Mao
qui lui a cessé de perdre de reconquérir
le pouvoir
il y a une chose importante dans ce
qu'elle dit que c'est le rapport à
l'URSS c'est-à-dire que depuis
1991 l'Occident regarde chaque nouveau
leader chinois en disant est-ce que ça
sera le Gorbatchev de la Chine et chaque
nouveau leader chinois se dit comment
montrer que je ne suis pas le Gorbatchev
chinois Gorbatchev c'est une insulte en
Chine c'est l'homme qui a fait tomber le
Parti communiste soviétique et même si
il y avait des désaccords entre les
Soviétiques et les Chinois c'est quand
même le fondateur du monde communiste et
et donc être le Gorbatchev c'est
faire courir un risque existentiel au
communisme et sitting
voulu montrer ça en fermant toutes les
portes de l'occidentalisation ou de la
menace occidentale dans la société
chinoise il y avait
dans les 15 ans qui ont précédé
l'arrivée de City au pouvoir une sorte
de zone grise en Chine dans laquelle il
y avait un début de société civile il y
avait des ONG il y avait des des
associations environnementales de
défense des malades du sida de lutte
contre les expulsions de de logement ou
les confiscations de terre des choses
comme ça c'est une pink a fermé tout ça
il a il a par exemple ça a été un des
coûts symboliques qu'il a fait au début
arrêté tous les avocats qui défendaient
des causes dites sensibles en Chine et
il n'était libéré que si signait un
engagement à ne plus
s'occuper de cas comme ça et sinon on
leur retirait leur licence et tout d'un
coup cet espace du droit de
l'utilisation du droit pour normaliser
un peu la société
c'est trouver refermé et c'est comme ça
que que cette ce gorbatchevisme rampant
qu'on pouvait voir dans cette montée en
puissance de société civile a été tuée
et aujourd'hui effectivement cet espace
là n'existe plus en Chine alors qu'il
existait il y a 20 ans c'est c'est un
phénomène je trouve très marquant de
l'air sitting qui est une fermeture et
non pas une ouverture surveillance de
masse ça fait partie intégrante ce
contrôle de la population de la
stratégie mise en place pour les raisons
qu'on a bien compris d'ailleurs avec vos
paroles tout à l'heure pierre ASCII
contrôle la population c'est l'assurance
que l'idéologie communiste et les choix
de son leader seront respectés et non
contestés il peut pas y avoir de
contestation aujourd'hui en Chine pas
d'opposition idéologique pas
d'opposition politique en tout cas c'est
la boîte à outils à la fois de
contraindre la population et d'essayer
de la convaincre à travers évidemment
l'appareil de propagande etc je parlerai
pas forcément du Crédit social puisque
c'est parfois beaucoup disputés parmi
les chercheurs sur la nature exacte de
ce qui existe ou pas
ce qui est clair par contre c'est la
surveillance généralisée de la
population à travers y compris
l'utilisation des nouvelles technologies
et ça une conséquence aussi en dehors de
Chine puisque ce qui est extrêmement
intéressant c'est que ça fait maintenant
des années que la Chine exporte
certaines technologies qui peuvent être
utilisées pour des contrôles de la
population pour des mises en œuvre de
pratiques autoritaires et aujourd'hui on
peut aller dans certaines villes en
Afrique en Asie du Sud-Est et même en
Amérique du Sud et voir que l'ensemble
des caméras de surveillance et des
systèmes de gestion des caméras ont été
par exemple sous-traités à des
entreprises chinoises et donc c'est
d'une certaine façon la capacité aussi
de la Chine d'exporter non pas un modèle
mais des pratiques et potentiellement
pour la Chine de tisser des liens en
termes de sécurité politique avec des
régimes autoritaires et pour revenir à
ce que disait précédemment pierre cette
notion de la sécurité politique elle est
fondamentale aujourd'hui il y a elle
explique en grande partie la façon dont
est compris fonctionne le Parti
communiste va être tenable
cette prise de contrôle cette tentative
de prise de contrôle de la population
chinoise il y a une classe moyenne qui
s'est créée en Chine avec
l'enrichissement de la population
chinoise qui fait partie des objectifs
d'ailleurs du régime l'enrichissement de
sa population il y a aussi l'épisode du
du covid ce formidable volte-face
chinois sur sur la stratégie à suivre en
matière de covid et ils l'ont là on a vu
apparaître des contestations importantes
au sein de la population c'est peut-être
pas aussi ça de continuer à pouvoir
contrôler cette population chinoise
est-ce qu'il y aura pas une fin à ce à
cette répression et ce contrôle
sur ce Terra là ce qui est clair c'est
qu'il peut évidemment y avoir à
mécontentement qu'il y a à
mécontentement en Chine après la
question c'est comment est-ce qu'il peut
ou non s'exprimer et comment le parti le
prend en compte et le réprime en grande
partie ce qui est clair c'est que le
parti n'est pas un organisme
monolithique et qu'il s'adapte on voit
notamment dans la façon dont ce qu'on
appelle le département du front uni qui
grosso modo est chargé en dehors du
parti
de s'assurer d'une cooptation ou d'une
sanction vis-à-vis de potentiels
opposants en dehors du parti une
évolution des pratiques avec par exemple
certaines classes de la population
depuis des nouvelles directives de
janvier 2021 qui sont maintenant plus
explicitement mentionnés qu'auparavant
c'était le cas il y a quelques années
des minorités religieuses des minorités
ethniques de plus en plus aussi de ce
qu'on appelle des classes sociales
émergentes grosso modo les urbains
éduquer relativement jeune il y a la
nécessité par le parti pour se maintenir
au pouvoir non seulement d'avoir des
sources de légitimité alors ce sera la
question dans les années à venir est-ce
qu'il y aura ou non un nouveau contrat
social une forme de contrat social en
génocide mais aussi sur des moyens
évidemment de contrôle de la société de
contrôle extrêmement appuyé de la
société et ça ça évolue en permanence
je voudrais juste apporter une toute
petite précision sur le crédit social
qui est pas à proprement parler un outil
de surveillance mais plus un outil de
gouvernance pour restaurer une forme de
confiance entre les citoyens les
administrations les citoyens les
entreprises etc en l'absence d'un état
de droit qu'est-ce que vise crédit
social c'est assez difficile d'en parler
parce que c'est un système extrêmement
hybride opéré par pluralité d'acteurs
qui n'ont rien à voir ensemble il y a
des administrations il y a des
entreprises il y a des gouvernements
locaux etc bon et chacun avec un
objectif particulier mais en gros ça
l'idée pour les administrations c'est de
s'assurer par exemple que les décisions
de justice soient respectées qu'elles
soient appliquées que les citoyens
payent leurs factures leur intégrité de
gaz etc que alors voilà et au niveau
local par exemple c'est une entreprise
disciplinaire par exemple faire en sorte
que que les gens soient plus civiles
dans le sens où ils traversent dans les
clous ou etc etc et sur le plan des
entreprises c'est plus s'apparente plus
à des programmes de fidélité si vous
achetez
plus de produits chez nous on vous
récompense avec des points de fidélité
etc alors il y a aussi un outil de
souriant
pour la population
dont fait l'objets les Ouigours par
exemple ou la surveillance de masse elle
joue à plein part ces deux choses
différentes la surveillance avec les
caméras le fait de prélever l'ADN etc et
de crédit social le Crédit Social c'est
un outil de gouvernance
de fait qui fonctionne avec carotte à la
bâton c'est à dire des récompenses et
des sanctions qui sont une sanctions qui
sont parfois complètement
disproportionnées par rapport puisque
par exemple on peut empêcher des voyages
on peut empêcher des parents de mettre
leur enfant à l'école du coin on peut
empêcher
qu'elle prenait le taxi aujourd'hui on
paye avec des applications sur
smartphone qui prélèvent directement
l'argent sur sur son compte bon ben elle
s'est retrouvée pour une course de taxi
en déficit son compte bancaire et la
sanction ça a été qu'elle n'a pas pu
prendre de crédit immobilier pour
s'achir un appartement donc pour vous
dire la
disproportion des sanctions etc mais
c'est d'une manière générale un outil
plus de discipline d'incitation à être
civilisé et
d'application des règles en absence et
des décisions de justice en absence d'un
état de droit c'est pas à proprement
parler à une autre petite surveillance
le problème par contre et c'est là où je
vous rejoins au niveau de la
surveillance c'est que ces données elles
peuvent être utilisées par la police etc
et à des fins politiques bon moi je
voulais qu'on parle du covid parce qu'il
en est question bien entendu dans ce
documentaire on a avancé depuis la fin
de ce documentaire avec ce véritable
volte-face auquel on a eu droit ces
derniers mois concernant la Chine et
c'est contestations jamais vu depuis 89
tienen men tout le monde tous les
spécialistes de la Chine ont populaire
ont l'air d'accord sur le sujet ça veut
dire que cette ce contrôle de la
population il a ses limites aussi non et
rejoignent une chose que disait en toi
tout à l'heure qui était le l'idée du
contraste social parce que même dans un
pays totalitaire il y a un contrat
social et ce contrat social qui est
celui qui a instauré denxiaoping après
tian'anmène qui était en gros
enrichissez-vous le parti vous garantit
cet enrichissement et la grandeur de la
Chine et en échange en gros vous la
fermez sur les questions politiques vous
laissez le pouvoir aux parties pour s'en
occuper et là on voit bien qu'en ce
moment sur la question du covid et aussi
sur la question du du ralentissement
économique ce contrat social est menacé
parce que c'était quoi le la question du
covid c'était la protection de la
population on a vendu pendant trois ans
à la population chinoise l'idée que la
fermeture des frontières faire la chasse
au moindre cas de covid c'est à dire que
quand vous avez 5 4 covid dans une ville
de 15 millions d'habitants on va boucler
la ville
cette idée là qui faisait partie de ce
cette idée de protection elle est
apparue tout d'un coup veine et et
inefficace et en particulier il y avait
ce gag au moment de la coupe du monde de
football où les gens se sont rendus
compte tout d'un coup qu'au kata il y
avait des dizaines de milliers de
personnes dans les dans les stades sans
masque qui s'embrassait quand il y avait
un but et et et que personne ne bourrait
pour autant et donc il y a eu cette
faille
absolue dans la confiance qu'on pouvait
avoir dans le discours officiel qui
s'est révélé
inopérante au moment du covid qui a
généré ces manifestations et ce
retournement
anti shising les slogans
anti-particulaires inédits et mais ça
rejoint aussi le malaise plus général
qu'il y a en ce moment dans la classe
moyenne parce que c'est cette classe
moyenne qui est devenue la base sociale
du parti et qui aujourd'hui se retrouve
avec des failles dans le la promesse
d'enrichissement la crise de
l'immobilier qui est apparue
est une catastrophe parce que
l'immobilier c'est le cœur de la
construction de la classe moyenne et
aujourd'hui les prix de l'immobilier
sont devenus
absolument gigantesque et tout nouvelle
tout nouvel aspirant à entrer dans la
classe moyenne ne peut plus aujourd'hui
remplir les conditions et deuxièmement
le chômage des jeunes diplômés vous avez
20 % de 20% un chiffre officiel 20% ce
qui est ce qui est un vrai problème
parce que vous avez une génération
d'enfants uniques les parents se sont
sacrifiés on fait tout ce qu'il fallait
pour que leur enfant accède à
l'université et sorte diplômé et il y a
pas la récompense à la fin les routes de
la soie comme symbole
ce que nous décrit le documentaire comme
l'expansionnisme qui serait une marque
de fabrique l'expansionnisme chinois qui
serait devenu la marque de fabrique de
sigin ping à la tête de la République
populaire de Chine de quelle
expansionisme parle-t-on au-delà de
cette fameuse route de la sociologie
qu'on a Ventoux une internationalisation
et que ce soit Chine ping ou quelqu'un
d'autre la même dynamique aurait opéré
puisqu'elle est plus ancienne elle a
vraiment du début des années 2000 alors
on peut dater à l'entrée dans l'OMC ou
autre mais disons que la Chine a des
intérêts de plus en plus mondialisé elle
a des besoins de plus en plus mondialisé
ça se traduit dans tous les domaines y
compris sur le domaine militaire fin
2008 début 2009 la Chine mène les
premières opérations de lutte contre la
piraterie dans le golfe d'Aden au large
de l'Afrique en 2011 elle commence des
premières des premières opérations
d'évacuation de ressortissants chinois
depuis la Libye en partenariat avec les
autorités européennes et les Marines
notamment Méditerranée puis en 2015 du
Yémen en 2017 elle ouvre la première
base même si elle ne la pèse pas ainsi
prêt à base militaire hajiboutique donc
on a une internationalisation des
intérêts de la Chine et pour aller avec
cela une stratégie qui est de plus en
plus globale sur les routes de la soie
ce qui est intéressant dès le début
c'est que c'est pas simplement un projet
d'infrastructure c'est à vous tout un
projet dans lequel la Chine a
parfaitement conscience que par rapport
aux États-Unis elle a de nombreux
faiblesses et qui a bien un domaine dans
lequel elle peut essayer de rivaliser
avec les États-Unis à l'époque il y a
quasiment 10 ans celle de Maine
économique et donc à la nécessité
d'accroître l'interdépendance voire même
une dépendance asymétrique avec d'autres
pays pour s'en servir comme des leviers
politiques et cette question de la
coercition économique chinoise il y a 10
ans quand on en parlait tout le monde
rigolait en disant non mais ça c'est des
Américains il y a que les Américains qui
font des sanctions extra-territoriales
il y a que des Américains qui font de la
coercition économique et bien non la
Chine en fait aussi on l'a vu à partir
de 2016-2017
la Corée du Sud on l'a vu en 2020 contre
l'Australie on l'a vu à partir de 2021
contre un État membre la Lituanie un
État membre de l'Union européenne et
donc on est une stratégie de plus en
plus globale je dirais pas forcément
qu'il y a une Chine qui sur le plan
militaire cherchent à conquérir quoique
évidemment emmerde mère de Chine
méridionale dans les trois Taïwan c'est
à notre sujet mais sur le continent
africain sur le continent américain on a
une Chine qui a de plus en plus
d'intérêt et qui surtout se dotent des
moyens de mettre en oeuvre et de
protéger de plus en plus ces intérêts
de quelle expansionnisme parle-t-on y
a-t-il un expansionnisme idéologique
très marqué cette volonté de prendre le
leadership aujourd'hui d'un espèce de
contre modèle face aux occidentaux sur
le plan planétaire c'est comme ça qu'on
en parle dans ce film finalement on a un
certain nombre de pays européens qui ont
poussé des coopérations très avancées
avec la Chine je pense à la Grèce qui a
vendu le port du Pirée et qui s'est
retrouvé dans une position où par
exemple la Grèce met maintenant son veto
au dépôt par l'Union européenne d'un
rapport annuel sur les droits de l'homme
en Chine qui était une tradition auprès
de la Commission des droits de l'homme
de l'ONU la Grèce a aujourd'hui des
rapports économiques et donc politique
avec la Chine qui font que elle la
protège d'une certaine manière par ce
type de geste donc on voit bien que on
n'est pas dans dans un expansionnisme
classique comme nous on l'a pratiqué
coloniale euh c'est-à-dire la conquête
de territoire l'installation de de
gouverneur et cetera on est dans une
stratégie d'influence qui sert d'abord
les intérêts économiques de la Chine
c'est évident la Chine est devenue le
premier partenaire non seulement de
l'Afrique et mais ça se sait moins de
l'Amérique latine la chasse gardée des
États-Unis le premier partenaire
économique aujourd'hui c'est la Chine et
la deuxième le deuxième volet de cette
expansionnisme c'est évidemment
l'influence politique on le voit dans
par exemple la manière dont la Chine a
investi les organisations du système des
Nations Unies et on l'a senti on parlait
du covid tout à l'heure au début de la
crise du covid monsieur tedros le
directeur général de l'OLM de la Santé
a fait tout ce que voulait la Chine
pendant les premières semaines
c'est-à-dire retarder la prise de
conscience internationale de l'ampleur
de la pandémie donc
on a là
fait direct de ce que peut être la
stratégie d'influence chinoise est-ce
que la guerre en Ukraine est devenue un
grain de sable
dans la stratégie chinoise
et où on a où en sont les relations
entre la Chine et la Russie aujourd'hui
depuis le début de cette guerre en
Ukraine ce qui est parti malheureusement
sur le titre pour durée la Chine ce
serait bien passé entre guillemets d'un
enlisement russe en Ukraine ça c'est
clair mais je pense que les fondamentaux
aujourd'hui de la relation sinorus des
fondamentaux qui sont encore une fois
liés à la question de la sécurité
politique et aujourd'hui le
rapprochement depuis nombreuses années
accéléré on se rappelle en février 2022
cette fameuse déclaration commune
Marc tous les facteurs et tous les
éléments qui traduisent que entre les
deux la question qui compte c'est celle
de la sécurité politique dans le sens où
la Chine n'est pas une menace pour le
régime russe et la Russie n'est pas une
menace pour le régime chinois donc on
n'a pas une Chine qui cette guerre est
une menace pour le business mondial
et ça les Chinois en ont horreur oui ça
fait évidemment monter les prix ça crée
des stress sur les prix internationaux
et en même temps c'est aussi des
opportunités pour la Chine y compris sur
le marché russe et puis la question est
autre c'est est-ce que la Chine a
vraiment envie aujourd'hui de jouer un
rôle de médiation des cieux de trouver
une solution à la Garonne je ne crois
pas un seul instant c'est vrai que
pendant longtemps on a décrit la
relation entre une relation entre ego et
que Poutine avait un ascendant de
l'antériorité et de la puissance
militaire russe et si il pique avait la
montée en puissance de l'économie
aujourd'hui les rôles sont un peu
inversés parce que
cette égalité a été rompue par l'échec
de Poutine en Ukraine et si ça ne met
pas en danger la relation ça change le
rapport de force entre Pékin et Moscou
en faveur de Pékin en faveur de Pékin
bien sûr je vous remercie beaucoup à
tous les trois l'avoir participé à ce
débat doc aujourd'hui consacré aux
ambitions au projet à l’idéologie à
laquelle se trouve aujourd'hui le numéro
un chinois et depuis maintenant plus de
10 ans si j'ai une pink vos réactions ça
sera sur hashtag des Badoc sur Twitter
bien entendu merci aussi à Salma Sally
qui comme à l'accoutumée m'a aidé à
préparer cette émission et puis moi je
vous retrouve tout simplement pour un
prochain débat doc et ça sera bien
entendu avec son documentaire et son
débat à très bientôt
[Musique]